dr. oz I'm here in Davos I've got an
email actually pushing from Carolina 12
07 10 mm what is Mexico she's asking how
do you think our global economy will be
in 35 over 10 years what we do to make
it better I think after being at Davos
for a couple days I'm very optimistic
about the global coming maybe not
releasing a thing we talked about health
issues here now we're gonna get ahead of
a lot of issues that may prevent you
from being healthy in life because
remember who cares if you're healthy if
you're wealthy rather do not help
yourself but what I really enjoyed using
conversation around I'm not being
connected again what ultimately i think
is falling out at the bottom of the
world economy is we're not going to each
other we don't trust each other we don't
trust other than the national level we
don't trust a global level we don't try
to trust each other in our companies and
alternate our families so there's a lot
of emphasis in the foundations of what
makes economies move forward and then
built on trust audio support smaller
groups and people doing things together
they know each other they therefore
trust each other this everything means
on about the huge companies lets them
thrive on their own let then be part of
the local economy it actually bounced
out of it open it provides a lot of
stability but also brings that intimacy
that connection bandit I think is in a
healthy kind of even crueler than xmas
leaders